اعتقدت أن كوين سارة تعيش لقد حصلت على سكن
حتى خط العنق من مسامير الموسم königsberg i
لذلك جاي شون الهاتف الذكي toronado
لنكون أصدقاء أركض ونفض الغبار بينما أرى
القمامة على التسلق أنا مافيا لي
سوف تمزق أجهزة الاستشعار المتربة من تذكرنا
فيلم النخيل
كان عمري 17 عامًا ، وصلت إلى المقدمة وهذا في الداخل
منطقة أقواس كبيرة أفرغت لنا
[موسيقى]
مررنا بالمواهب
يأتي الغسيل مهمة هذه الحماية
كان ذلك وولف هوفمان
خذ حرًا في المدينة كي لا يتنقلون و
الشرق المجاني قادم أنا لا أجدد
أصبح
عسل جليدي سريع
ذهبنا على طول هذا الطريق
أتيت هنا مع لسانك مخبأ أين
لن يغسل الملازم على المنحنى آذانهم
فكر قليلاً في القوة
تكريم فالكوفيتش بقلم يتحدث عن نفسه
الهاتف والجهاز يسمع نعم تسمع
مائة جنيه أنا طبقتها نفس الفرع الألماني
ها هي الآلة جاهزة
انهم يدوسون على الحشد يغني للحصول على طول الصورة
آخذ قنبلة العالم
1 قبل أن يرمي طائشًا حتى أعطى انفجارًا
خرجنا حتى تعرضوا للضرب من قبل البعض
كلاهما مضغوط على قيد الحياة
يرجى اتخاذ أفضل خطوة العين
الحرف
سيعود ويجلب هذه الألسنة أشعةنا
الشغل
كيف جريئة الرجال نعم
كانوا ذبابة بيضاء هنا في هذه الحالة و
جبان لكن هذه سلطتنا ونريد
دعنا نقول أن مجموعتنا ليست مثل مجموعتك
فرقة القفز لن تتراجع أبدًا
علينا أن نقتل
لن ينتهي به الأمر قبل معركة التذاكر جيدًا
نعم ، اعتبر ذلك في منطقتك
يتحسنون ، لقد كانوا فاشيين وكان لدينا
كان قومها بلدية الفيزياء و
لديك ذبابة لأفكار البيرة أنا
ولد في حي rozhdestveno Shchelkovsky
حتى يومنا هذا يعيش هناك درس في بلده
المدرسة الثانوية عيد الميلاد لمدة 9
صف دراسي
وبعد ذلك دخل في التربية
كلية
وبعد ذلك لم يتم استدعاؤه إليه
جيشنا هنا ثلاثة أشقاء كلهم ​​ثلاثة أشقاء
خدم الجد ربما هذه هي التعليمات
على والأداء حتى يتمكن الجيش من المشي
وهذا نوع من المدرسة نتواصل مع الجد
غالبًا ما نعيش في نفس القرية
استمع جيدًا للتعليمات هناك
نحاول المساعدة في كل شيء
أنا نفسي لدي حلم عزيز
كان العالم على الأرض ، والعياذ بالله هناك
البقاء على قيد الحياة ما خبرتنا هناك
الأجداد هناك الحادية والأربعون 45
سنوات ، هذا هو الحلم العزيزة ليس فقط
هناك ملكي
وأحيانًا الملايين من الناس
فخور بك يا جدي
من كل الناس الذين جعلونا
بلد سعيد جدا أو فريق
أرشيف بطل العالم
[موسيقى]